en este vídeo vamos a trabajar con
algunas medidas de dispersión en
estadística y para eso nos vamos a valer
de una serie de números tenemos entonces
al 65 el 81 el 73 el 85 el 94 el 79 el
67 el 83 y el 82
y ve de esta lista o de esta serie de
números
vamos a averiguar lo que es el rango
y lo que es el medio medio rango
para el rango lo que dice el rango es
que qué tan amplia o qué tan larga qué
tan extensa es nuestra serie o cuánto
abarca es decir lo que lo que tenemos
entre medio del último valor y el primer
valor qué distancia hay para averiguar
eso
tenemos que hacer el número mayor
el número mayor de la serie que tenemos
- el número menor
de esta forma siendo el número mayor -
el número menor vamos a ver cuánto
abarca o qué tan extensa es la serie o
la lista que tenemos fíjense que el
mayor de los números es el 94 y el menor
es el 65 por lo tanto
al hacer 94 - 65 vamos a conseguir el
rango que no es otra cosa que 29 es
decir que hay una distancia de 29 entre
el primero o el menor de los números y
el mayor de ellos entonces vamos a
aclarar esto vamos a dejarlo así no
vamos a borrar y vamos a ver ahora lo
que es el medio rango el medio rango nos
dice que es como una media aritmética o
un promedio entre el mayor de los
números que sería el 94 y el menor de
los números es decir el número
intermedio entre estos dos por lo tanto
si queremos buscar el número intermedio
entre el 65 y el 94 lo que vamos a tener
que hacer
y sumar los 94 65 65 60 y después
a esto buscar la mitad de ese resultado
es decir a todo esto dividido 2 y esto
nos da 79 5 es decir que el número que
está entre el 94 y el 65 es el 79,5 y
eso es el medio rango de nuestra lista
bueno entonces en este vídeo lo que
pudimos apreciar y comprender es el
concepto de rango y de medio rango de
una lista de números dados